you
hit the regulan permanent secretary of
the Swedish Academy thank you for
talking to us
could we begin by you telling us who's
received the 2010 Nobel Prize in
Literature the 2010 Nobel Prize in
Literature has been given to the
Peruvian author Mario Vargas Llosa and
why does Nobel Committee award the prize
to him well it actually is awarded by
the entire Academy but no because this
is one of the great Latin American even
Spanish speaking authorship in in the
spanish-speaking world and he has he was
one of the people sort of responsible
for the boom in Latin American
literature during the 60s and 70s with a
number of masterpieces starting with his
his first book the time of the hero I
think it's called in English when it was
just 25 years old and continued to
produce a number of very very respected
and I mean excellent works of fiction so
tell us a bit more about the author and
more about the major themes that he
explores in his work well my obayashi
also his 74 years old he's born and
raised in in Peru it was something of a
boy genius as I mentioned starting
writing he righted the wrote his first
book when he was some 25 years old he's
been part of the literary boom in Latin
America and he is basically a
storyteller a narrator but he is also a
very very special storyteller that has
evolved the literary waves of telling
stories they are often very complex in
composition his books his masterful when
it comes to dialog shifting time planes
to shifting persons always going for the
big picture this is not this is not a
and also that it drills a hole through
reality and calls it the world he is
going for that elusive thing called a
total novel so and the principal themes
I would say one of the important things
is breaking free rebellion
fighting against oppression in some kind
breaking free and then defeat so his is
talking about both rebellion making the
rebellion you understand why these
people had to do what they did you
understand it it seems inevitable and
then again he paints a picture of their
defeat because his books often end in
defeat when you also understand why
defeat was almost inevitable so he is
capable of holding several thoughts in
his head at the same time he's working
with it with a big panorama with many
many characters in his book sigh one of
his books conversations in the cathedral
I think there is 100-plus characters in
that book so you are not getting a
narrow view you are getting a sort of a
bird's eye view of Latin America and
part of its dilemma and he's not someone
who's just restricted to the novel
here's there's a range of literary style
yes his is a very versatile also he has
not just written these very big books
grounded in different ways in Latin
American history his right he's tried
almost virtually all genres he's written
I mean postmodern comedies erotic
fiction books that reminds you of
whodunit he's writing essays chronicles
journalism his first started writing by
working as a teenage journalist back in
Peru running around on crime scenes as
only his never really left journalism
has been reporting from both Gaza and
Iraq so he is a very multi-talented man
and so to the uninitiated reader where
would you recommend they begin to the
uninitiated reader I would recommend the
feast of the goat which is his book
about the Dominican Republic and the
assassination of the dictator the the
old long-standing dictator I refer to
and it's a one hand it's a masterful
narrative in the tradition that he has
evolved with with complicated
composition where people are different
strands of the story evolving into each
other you have different time planes you
have different characters on the one
hand on the other hand is it's a very
exact and chilling book on the inner
workings of a dictatorship not only the
the thing that the teachers do when they
sort of kill and torture and censor
people but also about moral corruption
the moral corruption dictation and so
it's a do you have to be politically
active to be noble worthy no not at all
no but just to say that's how does his
work fit in with the with the the
statutes the world where it's
outstanding work in an ideal direction I
think it actually fits he has been
working in this old tradition of say
even victor ego and onwards with you
know man of letters also being men of
action he believes in improving the
world he believes in fiction and the
power of fiction to improve the world
and if that's not an ideal direction I
don't know
thank you very much better England